it's funny when I first saw the movie
lilo and Stitch my initial thought was I
loved everything with the human
characters and thought the alien stuff
was only okay well now with the sequel
stitch I find that strangely enough the
human stuff is only okay but the aliens
are actually a little bit more
entertaining this time does that make
for a good sequel well let's look at the
story lilo and Stitch are enjoying their
time getting used to their new alien
family yeah remember the Russian alien
and the skinny one they're all living
together now but the alien kept out of
the garden fear is because he's lost his
job and he wants revenge till he comes
across this sort of strange hamster
rabbit thing with a German accent as all
these aliens have brute accents anyway
and he sent to get the Russian alien
bring him back and find out where all
the other experiments they worked on are
yeah remember stitch is number six to
six so where are the other 625 well it
turns out he's hidden them and lilo and
Stitch come across a few so it's up to
them not only to discover these other
experiments kind of like finding Pokemon
innocence but also to save their alien
comrade so like I said before this time
it's a little switched around the aliens
in this actually have some really good
labs this weird rapid gerbil thing is
pretty funny the captain of the guards
is trying to be serious but keeps having
to come across these annoyances even get
this psychic voiced by Rob Paulsen even
stitch gets a few more laughs this time
I also really like how the skinny alien
is actually really giving used to
wearing women's clothing and he's
totally okay with it who knows this
might be the first openly transvestite
Disney character unfortunately though
like I said the human characters are not
as good they're not the worst they're
just kind of bland and generic but for
me WEO is one of my favorite kid
characters and to see her just kind of
be like any other Disney generic kid is
really kind of a letdown even Nani who
had to go through so much in the first
film now it just kind of has this side
role I don't know I felt like coming off
the first film where those connections
were so strong and so good this one is
just kind of a background thing maybe
that's why it was called Stitch because
they just wanted to give him more
attention and not as much to the humans
but I liked the humans I liked them a
lot I wish more effort was put into him
and this one but let's also be honest
this isn't really meant to be a
fleshed-out motion picture I mean look
at the animation it looks like a TV show
and yeah it became a TV show it's a
little difficult to be hard on it when
it's pretty obvious it's just supposed
to be a pilot
well this pilots going got a few laughs
the aliens were neat they were creative
I liked the idea of trying to find more
of them in fact I think that's what the
show is about but yeah it is a letdown
that a character as good as Nani and
lilo or just reduce down to well any
generic character you would see in a
Disney sequel but I guess if you're just
looking for a laugh or two and something
relatively harmless it's fine that's
fine for little kids I think that's who
it was aimed at and there's nothing
really insulting in it I mean lilo Nami
are not done well but they're totally
passable for the audience it's aiming
towards it is what it is a cute little
directed DVD pilot for a TV show and
yeah you just can't take what comes with
that I wouldn't watch it again I don't
really think I got much out of it even
watching it the first time but for what
it's trying to do we it does it okay get
lost in space and see for yourself
[Music]
you